[Music]
I thought it would be fun this weekend
for me and the writers as a group to do
something together like kind of Sunday
Funday Sunday Funday don't don't I have
Sunday fun you guys want Sunday Funday
they have to I pay
them uh so we had a Sunday fund day and
we went to the zoo as a group we
actually have a photo this is from this
weekend at the zoo
yeah yeah not a real lizard but it was
fun it was a fun time I mean who goes to
the zoo turns out kids with their
parents and one creepy group of
childless adult
Riders our ideas are our
babies you will not see one single grown
person at the zoo even the creeps are
like it's two on the
notes eating anything at the zoo is
weird eating meat at the zoo is weird I
saw a lot of people eating meat yeah no
that's the right response it's strange
to be clutching a hamburger eating it
while you make eye contact with a
caribou your cousin needs
ketchup you're a dry
people it's uncomfortable you know what
else is uncomfortable watching some
animals get the big spaces and other
animals get the small there's all these
politics to it I have to imagine it's
got to be weird for the animals in the
small spaces like I saw a tiger just one
tiger he was alone in a huge pen he had
trees trees multiple huge trees he had a
river like an active waterfall an
inactive waterfall you wouldn't see
it he had a waterfall he had giant cat
toys which was fun but right across from
all this stuff there was a twocan just
in a glass
box he had like a view of the tiger just
sitting there just like
really now I see big Mr tiger he a crown
pleaser so he gets an anchor of land
okay but is he host in
bonaro meanwhile I'm over here in a
phone booth not like I could use the
space like I can fly or
anything used to be a colorful beak
would open some doors in this
town that is my favorite part of the
monologue and a lot of you s it out and
that makes me sad a tan to himself going
colorful beak used to mean
something the cages are weird too all of
the cages a lot of the cages would have
on the back wall you know it just be
like a ceramic wall but they would paint
on it like a painting of the outdoors
have you seen that that's got to be fun
and convincing on the first day you know
I mean gorillas going up to it like the
end of The Truman
Show
just like oh this isn't so bad look at
look at that look at that beautiful feel
oh
you
you I am going to beat my chest about
this
the zoo I went to actually had a
tarantula tarantula tarantula
tarantula who is going to the zoo like
rhinos elephants whatever where's the
tarantula some basement dwelling lunatic
just like it's just not a Saturday until
I see a crab made of
goatees
tarantula but the zoo was fun it was the
highlight of the whole day was I went
and saw the uh Chinese monkeys they have
this little house it's all glass and you
can watch them and my timing was perfect
I walked into this packed room there was
about 15 kids uh maybe six adults and
just as I walked in there's one monkey
on a branch another monkey climbed up to
him just to hug him they hugged it was
beautiful exact that's what we did just
a room full of children
like it was amazing and in that moment
we saw these majestic creatures loving
each other just perfectly meanwhile
while us the more evolved humans all we
did was capture them and put them in a
cake so you felt us being like who's the
real animal
here and then the monkey stopped hugging
one turned around and the other Dove
face first into his
ass
and everyone was like oh yeah it's them
they're the
[Applause]
[Music]
animals